[Music]
so
ah
count dracula
the werewolf
and frankenstein
our classic monsters are back once again
in spirit form
what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture and we are here at king's cross
to bring you a brand new spanking series
called the thirsty geek
all of this can be done in your very own
home so be sure to check out the full
recipe link in the description below
without further ado let's get on to
making some drinks
starting with a very endearing charming
yet fiendish count dracula drink we call
this
the bloodlust
this haunted drink will quench your
thirst for the life-giving liquid or
perhaps serve this alluring cocktail to
dispel your victims so for our
ingredients we'll need
kalua
we will also need some vodka any
preference of your choice and the lovely
lovely frangelico which is a hazelnut
liqueur
some peach schnapps
some lime to squeeze
some grenadine berry syrup some
blueberries
as well as a martini glass and some ice
so
let's get to it
so what you gotta do first is you gotta
chill your martini glass so add some ice
put a little bit of water if not you can
if you already have a martini glass put
it in the chiller for a little while set
it aside and let's focus on the drink so
we've got a boston glass get yourself a
shot of vodka or 30 ml
we're going to use a [__] over here
and we're just going to pour it nicely
into that glass
and of course 15 ml of frangelico which
is half a [__] or half a shot
next is your peach schnapps 15 ml half a
shot
here we go
a
squeeze of lime
right there
and next fill this up all the way device
so
grab a shaker oh that's
[Music]
[Laughter]
grab your shaker
bam and walk it up
up down up down
ah there we go
you gotta do a little dance
make sure it gets cloudy
and
boom and take it out
all right
take away
the water from your
martini glass
nice and chilled
once your martini glass is nice and
chilled add a half a shot of kalua
coffee liqueur
take a strainer and your mixture
as well as the bar spoon
put it over to the edge like this and
the trick is that you do not want to
interrupt the layer of kaluga over there
so
gently uninterrupted slowly
slowly pull
slowly
very slowly
very
slowly
until it's about three quarters full
[Music]
it's gonna take a while
to knock that
voila
once you're done with that take your bar
spoon again
fill it with one and a half shots
[Music]
of grenadine or raspberry syrup so what
you want to do is gently pour
what
okay that's a little bit too much but
it's still good you want to drip it
near the outer rim of the glass
so you get that nice
bloody
effect
beautiful
right
wonderful
and to finish it it's either you pop
them into your drink or just cut a
little slit into the blueberry and then
just decorate the rim
like so we're just gonna use
two
and voila you got yourself the bloodlust
how does it taste
well you don't need to ask cheers guys
[Music]
oh
nice bite a lot of sweetness coming from
the grenadine and then you got a little
bit of that sharp bitterness from the
kahlua that's sure to wake you up so
yeah moving on to the next one
and if you want to run with the pack
this cocktail is sure to make you howl
at the moon this is a twist on the salty
dog what we like to call
yes you spelled it like that be careful
with these though because they
they they pack a punch
it's gonna hit you right in the face
yes
so let's get started all you need is
three shot glasses or more depending on
how much you're making
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
salt rim them so take
a piece of lime and rim the shot glass
like so
take like a flat plate or something to
get the salt to sit on it so
we have a nice platform over here just
gonna lightly coat
the
shot glass
with salt
dab it a little bit
so the excess salt can come off
and repeat for your other
glasses yeah
once you've soldered your glasses it's
time to make the mixture grab a bustling
glass and a shaker one shot or 30 ml of
tequila
[Applause]
[Music]
one shot of kahlua coffee liqueur
and a shot of your favorite citrus juice
we recommend yuzu
grab some ice to fill up your mixture
it's time to dance guys
and once you feel that your shaker is
cold you know it's done
look it up
and
take
a straighter
[Music]
grab another strainer we want to use a
pointed one because it's short glasses
and just gently pull
[Music]
and you could probably have enough for
what five shots i'm gonna say five shots
five shots
and there you have it guys this is the
shooters they gotta try so guys
bottoms up
[Applause]
oh
good good good
you get the uh you get the sweetness and
the
a little bit of a tang from the yuzu
juice and the kalua just cuts that
sweetness with a little bit of
bitterness
and as well i mean focus is strong man
you get that mouth feel from the salt
probably a little bit too much but yeah
this is a fun one
okay fine one more one more we're gonna
save that one
let's go
[Music]
ah okay
and with this next cocktail bring
yourself back to life hit it
wake me up inside
[Music]
okay
with the modern prometheus the monster
himself
frankenstein we call this next drink
it's alive
the time is alive
because it got like green little like
wormy things that i think you enjoy and
so yeah this next drink is stitched
together with a blend of perfectly
splendid liqueurs that is sure
to bring you back to life
or make you die it really depends
it really depends
all you need is a tall glass
all right fill it up with ice
[Music]
so all you need is bakari or any of your
favorite white rum
one shot or 30
ml
into the glass
half a shot of kahlua
or
coffee liqueur
have a shot of midori or melon liqueur
to just get that nice greeny
effect and one shot or 30 milliliters of
malibu round coconut rum
here we go
[Music]
top up your glass with more eyes all the
way to the brim and last but not least
take some greenish jelly what we have
here is pandan cendol so just find maybe
green gummy bears or green jelly and
just top it all off all you need to do
is just scoop some just get some of that
nice green juice over there
be generous with your toppings
wonderful
excellente
there we go
don't drink it just like that
grab a nice straw
give it a nice swirl so you know you can
get all that jelly around
[Applause]
nice and
ominous and
and just take a sip and have fun right
so
oh yeah
i just gotta pack a bunch
can taste the panda
from the cendol bits
you can taste through the coconut rum
and all the other
liqueurs that's inside but this is
be careful with this one man and there
you have it our monster mesh of drinks
that you can do at home be sure to give
us a thumbs up if you enjoyed this video
and leave a comment down below telling
us what other geeky inspired drinks you
would like us to do and if you haven't
already do consider subscribing and
smash that notification bell icon so you
can stay updated to our future episodes
geeky news and tidbits until then this
is zaki signing off you know what time
it is
sunset sunset set set
everybody
[Music]
you